how does he came in with two legs and
two arms in a head create a physiology
which is capable of running it to our
marathon the first really important task
is to pick your parents correctly you've
got to be born to run that fast you can
work as hard as you want and you can
pull in all the science but the thing we
won't don't want to do is say Oh Kip
Jogi ran it's up to our Marathon because
there was a bunch of science and it made
it easy it's like no there's still only
one human in the world who could have
done this there's you know all the other
great runners in the world you know
massively talented have worked hard
they're still not at could Jovi's level
Kip Jogi is a super special guy he's got
the physical tools and maybe just as
importantly or at least but part of the
package he's got the mental tools he's
been at the top since 2003 he won a
World Championships as a teenager 16
years ago and that's unheard of nobody
has that sort of look or almost nobody
has that sort of longevity
Alex Hutchinson has joined us again Alex
welcome the show thanks a lot Chris it's
great to be back it is timely to talk
about endurance and running this is the
where the like the genesis point of the
the new world of running right now right
yeah it's it's it's certainly an
exciting time put it this way I did
Canadian radio this morning I'm talking
to you talking to New Zealand radio in a
few hours and then Australia a few hours
after that so people are talking about
endurance right now and hey I'm happy to
see it that you are so for those of you
who don't already follow Alex if you
have even the slightest interest in
running at sweat science on Twitter
ever since the podcast that we did at
the start of the year I only follow I
think I fell about 82 people or
something on Twitter so you make up more
than like about 2% of probably what what
I see on Twitter and the articles that
you've been putting out recently been
fascinating so we're going to go through
le capture gaez recent marathon
performance there's some really awesome
breakdowns that you've done in a
build-up to that and then afterwards
then we're going to talk about some
other records have been broken there's
some controversy surrounding the shoes
and the kit that people have been
wearing so we got we got a lot to get
through today it's gonna be exciting
fantastic yeah it's been it's been a
busy week so we'll have lots to talk
about cool so let's let's start with
Kipchoge most recent performance let's
say that someone somewhere has been
living under a rock and doesn't know
what's happened can you describe what
the INEOS 159 challenge was yeah for
sure so you know the big headline the
top headline is a human being ran less
they're faster than two hours for forty
two point two kilometers 26.2 miles the
marathon distance the second headline is
but it wasn't a world record it's not an
official world record it was it was not
doesn't count under the official rules
and that's where things start getting a
little a little tricky so this was this
race was an exhibition race held on
streets in Vienna a park in in a park in
Vienna only one competitor Elliot kept
Chokey who is the reigning Olympic
champion and official world record
holder but every
possible thing anyone could imagine to
make him faster was done the the
reported budget this is just rumors the
reported budget was 15 million pounds
for this one race by one person and so
this is what made it exciting and
interesting for for people like me who
are interested in this sort of the
science of endurance but also made it
controversial made it you know people
felt it was a bit of a stunt a marketing
stunt maybe even a sport washing stunts
for any us but so they had you know they
had an electric car driving in front of
them at exactly two hour marathon pace
shining lasers on the ground so that his
teams of you know I took there a total
of 41 world-class runners who were
serving as pacemakers for him blocking
the wind in in teams of I I think it was
one two three four five I think seven
pacemakers at a time we're trying to you
know encompass him or cocoon him from
the the forces of of drag and they were
a knew exactly where to run because the
the car was shining lasers on the ground
you know he had a guy on a bicycle
handing him water bottles every few
kilometres which is instead of you know
he didn't want to slow him down by
having to pick up a bottle off the table
and he had these wacky prototype shoes
on that nobody else basically nobody
else has has seen a runnin which are the
latest iteration of a pair of shoes
called the Nike Vapor fly which in the
last three years has basically rocked
the running world and totally reshaped
what people think
shoes are capable of doing for us so all
this stuff has boiled into you know
people didn't think he could do it
people aren't sure whether it's fair
people aren't sure whether it's a good
or a bad thing that we've got this
exhibition event that won't count as a
world record and so basically everyone
in the running world is having a big
massive brawl about it yeah I can
imagine there's so many different people
right because for me is someone who I
don't have a apart from entertainment
and a genuine interest in sport and
fitness I don't have a side here I'm I
would you know if someone could run a
one-hour marathon like sweet I had he
had Rockets on his feet but you know
he's still running or whatever
I just want the entertainment value but
I imagine there's some sport purists out
there who are going to be much more
critical so to set the scene no matter
what the shoe is and the track and the
paces and the car and stuff like that
how does someone how does he came in
with two legs and two arms and a head
create a physiology which is capable of
running it two hour marathon yeah so the
first really important task is to pick
your parents correctly you need you've
got to be born to run that fast there's
only you know you can work as hard as
you want and you can pull in all the
science but the only person you know the
the the the thing we won't don't want to
do is say Oh Kip Jogi ran it's up to our
Marathon because there was a bunch of
science and it made it easy it's like no
there's still only one human in the
world who could have done this there's
you know all the other great runners in
the world you know massively talented
have worked hard they're still not at
Kip jokey's level Kip Jogi is a super
special guy he's got the physical tools
and maybe just as importantly or at
least but part of the package he's got
the mental tools he's got he's been at
the top since 2003 he won a World
Championships as a teenager sixteen
years ago and that's unheard of nobody
has that sort of look or almost nobody
has that sort of longevity so he's been
he's the classic he grew up in the Rift
Valley of Kenya and at altitude it's
it's a total cliché four world beater
runners but you know running back and
forth from school hugely active as a kid
accumulating more training as that you
know as an eight-year-old than most like
university age runners even serious
runners in Canada where I am or in
Britain would and then started training
seriously he's been doing it year after
year week after week hundreds you know
he was running reportedly in the
neighborhood of 140 miles a week leading
up to this so that's we're talking well
over 200 kilometers a week some of that
at a relaxed pace some of that at
absolutely inhumanly fast pace and and
and you know one of the cool things I
think one of the things that makes
people root for Kip Jogi is he got a lot
of publicity
two years ago there was a very similar
attempt sponsored by Nike called
breaking to where he came within 25
seconds that time of breaking two hours
and there was a documentary that that
National Geographic put out about his
preparations for that and it gave people
a window onto this guy who is probably
one of the richest men in Kenya he has a
wife and a few kids he visits them on
weekends but he spends his week days at
this totally Spartan training camp where
he lives with other runners you know
it's just like it's not quite mud hut
but it's it's absolutely Spartan he you
know they have a roster he takes turns
mom you know mopping out the toilet
washing from you know getting water from
the well and washing from it you know he
could live like an absolute Sultan there
but he is a very simple guy and he's got
all these aphorisms about how if you
know if you don't control your mind your
mind controls you and so he's just he's
totally focused on performance and he he
lives this hard life very simple life
trains and so this is a long answer but
the point is this moment has been you
know not years in the making but decades
in the making and he's worked very very
hard to to become the the you know
absolutely running machine that he is
now yeah I think one of the things that
fascinates me and a lot of people with
Kip Jogi is the fact that he has this
monastic very zen-like transcendent
quality that he'd about his sport or
it's not even his sport is its life or
his calling whatever he wants to refer
to as but then he gets thrust into this
world where there's a guy on a bike
giving him water during the race then
when they takes the bottle of water back
they measure how much water's been drank
offset how much they know he needs
because they've done muscle fiber tests
to work out how much he dehydrates so
you have this this beautiful kind of
Union yang of the the real technological
cutting edge stuff that's attached to
someone who has this purity a very back
to basics approach to running I think
that's what makes it interesting you're
absolutely right there's this amazing
Jeff
to position and so you know two years
ago when he was doing this first Nike
race I had a chance to chat with him a
few times and you know I was I'm a
science journalist so I was like I want
to know all about the formulation of the
the drink you're using and and you know
how are you gonna alter your training
distribution blah blah blah and he's a
smart guy like he knows what's going on
so I don't want to make it sound like
he's just like oh the scientists take
care of it but he knows what his job was
and he knows the science was not his job
so he was able to in the midst of this
sort of massively scientific and and
let's face it commercial enterprise his
job was just to to run and to look
within himself and and you know learn to
push his limits and he was able to
maintain that so I would ask him all
these questions he'd be like yeah that
stuff's important and I leave that to
the scientific team my job is to is to
train my mind and be ready to go and I
think that's one of the you know I think
when Nike chose him two years ago they
were lucky that they got him because
that's one of the reasons this whole
endeavor has this sort of magical
feeling to it and rather than feeling
like a sort of Barnum & Bailey it's like
he stepped right up and see the the you
know the fattest woman in the world or
whatever it's like he gives it a purity
because he really like he comes off as
absolutely sincere so what you said I
think it that juxtaposition is
absolutely fascinating he's a great guy
so just before we get onto the race
itself and in the course of the course
choice and stuff like that
physiologically Elliott is he if you
were to design a runner in a lab I
remember reading a while that goes
something to do with long shin bones
being genetically something which is
disproportionately more in Kenyan
athletes which you means that they're
good and then they need to like feats
and other bits and pieces and vo2 max
and running efficiency how does all that
tie together for him you you've been
reading the right stuff yeah I'm
following you on Twitter Alex that's
what's been happening you know there's
been this great mystery for the last 20
years why are the Kenyans so good and
let's figure out if we can copy it
somehow and so there's all these all
these things like you said
so there's going back decades there's
been fascinating experiments where it's
like okay let's take a light weight you
know a few ounces and let's strap it
onto someone's foot or their shin or
their hip or wherever and let's see how
they're running efficiency changes and
what you find sort of not surprisingly
is the farther away from the center of
your body a weight is the harder it is
the more I mean you can think about that
you know you hold a weight up in front
of you it's one thing you hold your arm
out straight and hold a weight up it's a
lot harder so if you have weight a
little bit of extra weight a tiny bit of
extra weight on your feet for instance
with shoes that changes your efficiency
quite a bit so what that means is that
it's very advantageous to have very long
but skinny like no calf muscle legs and
that gives you these levers that can
propel you forward without paying that
weight penalty so you know then this
happens to be a sort of typical
characteristic of people who grew up in
the area that hip Jogi grew up in was
Kip Jogi is control key a perfect
running machine so when Nike first
embarked on this project a few years ago
they I mean and they sponsor a pretty
large fraction of the best runners in
the world so they said they brought
about more than two dozen of their best
runners into the lab to say let's let's
get out the calipers let's get out the
treadmills let's measure all these guys
and see who has the greatest endurance
capacity and capture ghee was not at the
top of the heap did you know who by
those measurements there's a guy named
ELISA de sisse
who actually won the World Championships
this year so very good runner he and he
used one Boston a couple of times so
he's he's good and and they could see in
the lab that he was off the charts but
he has never run as fast as Kip shogi as
Kip Jogi had good like he had the kind
of vo2 max and lactate threshold and
running economy that you need to be a
world-class runner but he didn't have
the kind that makes you say this guy's I
want any generation talent he said he's
a world-class runner but whatever makes
him once-in-a-generation is something
that doesn't show up in those lab tests
how amazing is that but how cool is that
to hear that you've got this guy who is
you know he's elite level but not a
freak and there's something which can't
be measured because everyone talks about
it in sport right they all talk about
this X Factor but I think increasingly
now as we get
to the 21st century and we have pundits
who are able to analyze with increasing
dexterity and resolution on what's
happening we're becoming more and more
cerebral about sport we think more and
more about the quantifiable metrics and
to hear that we have someone that's got
this difficult to define X Factor AIDS
is so much it's just easy here oh yeah
and you know it's interesting because
for me again I'm all about the science
I'm very interested in and you're
absolutely right that our ability to
analyze and understand the the basis of
a success is getting better and better
but for me the moment we reached the
point where you can go into a lab
measure ten people and and tell you tell
you with 99% certainty who's going to
win a race and who isn't that's the
moment to me that sport loses its its
interest in a way if you if everything
becomes quantifiable then it's like it's
just sport you know a race becomes a
plumbing contest who's got the biggest
hey order or whatever and that's isn't
it there has to be there has to be some
something that we can't measure for it
to be interesting so yeah to me that's
that's that's some of the magic and you
know I'll tell you talk about the X
Factor I guess I met kept Chokey for the
first time you know what three years ago
maybe and it's easy to say this in
hindsight but he he has a presence that
is that is hard to quantify it's like
I'm not gonna say I knew that moment
that you know he was gonna break two
hours but it's like this guy has the
yeah you know some people some people
just have a presence where it's like
this you know it's not a swagger because
he's very humble and very quiet but you
just you you feel that he's bigger than
he is and and you know that's I think
that's something that in someone
unquantifiable way that plays into his
abilities I'd love to see him at a party
talking about swagger like apparently he
likes to spin the tunes he was he was he
he there was a big dance that night and
he was giving out prizes to all of his
the Pacemakers these world class runners
who paced him but yeah he he's not like
a super party guy but I think he can get
down after you've just run a sub two
hour marathon you gotta at least have a
beer or something right
you gotta chill out somehow yeah yeah
you gotta go to unwind he takes a month
off after a marathon like that and just
chills us he's not one of these
obsessive people is like okay I've
already taken 12 hours off out to get my
next workout him he goes hard then he
then he relaxes and has a good time
talking about the way that he has
presence there's a clip and if anyone
goes back and watches the intro to the
race so the Pacemakers at the very very
beginning of the race the Pacemakers are
all there and then Elliott walks through
this gap in the barriers behind them and
I remember so I haven't watched the full
race it was a silly time last week if it
was in the UK and I'd work late and bla
bla and I watched this clip and it looks
I know this sounds weird and existential
but it it looks like the universe just
parts around him as he walks through
those barriers and it's like it's like
he's not moving the universe is moving
around him and he just part straight man
and you can just the way he looks you
know he's there with his that look on
his face and it's just that's just where
he's meant to be so getting on to
getting on to the race itself why did
they choose Vienna yeah it was a sort of
global search for for trying to find the
best of all possible worlds for a bunch
of different factors they had to
optimize one was they wanted a course
that was flat as flat as possible with
as few sharp turns as possible they
needed to get the temperature and the
altitude and the humidity and all these
things right even from a logistical
perspective they needed to find a place
where the city was willing to say yeah
we can guarantee you access to this for
like a two-week period because they
didn't want to just say we're gonna run
this race on October 12th or whatever
they what they said when they when they
plan is we're gonna run it sometime
between I think it was like October 10th
and 23rd or something like that and they
were gonna decide at the last minute
based on the weather forecast because if
it happens to be a little warm or a
rainy or something they weren't gonna do
that so there were a button and you know
when they initially searching for places
they they considered all sorts of
options they considered the world's
largest indoor Convention Centre or
least North America largest corn
convention center in North America and
Chicago
it's so it's indoors climate-controlled
perfectly flat huge the problem with
that one was that the air-conditioning
in the in the building wasn't strong
enough to get it as cold as they wanted
no they considered a dyke in the
Netherlands which is perfectly flat for
like 23 miles or something like that and
has a really reliable tailwind in one
direction so you could be let's just run
straight along this dyke with a wind
blow they decided that would feel too
much like cheating yep so and they even
considered building like ice walls along
a track that would keep keep it locally
cool yeah I mean they were they were and
then like the Nike one ended up on a
Formula one track in northern Italy so
it was like a 1.5 mile loop then Vienna
gave them longer straightaways and
crucially the one thing that's different
really from between the Nike race two
years ago and the NUS race this year his
capture gear on crowd support he wanted
people cheering it was it was sort of
deathly quiet on the Formula one track
aside from just at the finish line there
were a few people some people cheery it
was eerie when myself wasn't it yeah it
was like 5:00 in the morning
so kept Jogi wanted wanted people
cheering and he got that in Vienna and
and you know I I actually think if I if
I were designing it I would want it to
be deathly quiet for the first like 20
to 25 or 30 K cuz the marathon is
supposed to feel easy for a long time
and you don't want to get too excited
too early in the race
so my often well if I were designing it
would be totally quiet relaxed just
chilling out for 25-30 K and then then
open the game just when it's getting
hard then you get some with some crowd
for the next yeah you get like medium
crowd so you kind of want a crew you
want to have a volume control in the
crowd that brings it brings it up but
anyway he got a crowd in vnn so that's
probably the the main difference from
the last attempt this route if anyone
was to look at it there's some go to a
sweat science on Twitter and you'll be
able to see it
um from an aerial view it's like a
lollipop stick it's like a long thin
thing with a little bump at one end and
then long all the way back with a longer
roundabout at the top end and then you
go back down one of the concerns that
I'd seen you talking about was what the
corners do or corner that's this sharp
right you gotta do 180 degrees in the
space of is that 25 meters something
like that yeah so the radius of
curvature was actually if you think
about a standard Athletics track you
know 400 meter track and one of those
little lollipop ends was tighter than
the curves on a track and so that was a
concern and they got in touch with a guy
at the University of Colorado who's one
of the world experts in in running
biomechanics and they had him build a
model of how much does it slow you down
or how much extra energy does it take to
go around a curve and and not to get too
deep into the the vector diagrams and
forces and stuff but if you're going
around a curve you've got you've the
force of gravity is always pressing you
down and that's a big factor in how much
energy you spend running then you've
also got to spend a little extra energy
turning so pushing into the curve and
the result is that you effectively the
way you can think about it is you weigh
a little bit more when you're going
around a corner and what they calculated
is on the tight corner the extra weight
was the equivalent as if Kip shogi was
carrying two and a half cups of water
with him so he's that much heavier when
going around the corner and what they
and so they ran the calculations and
they decided it's no big deal it's that
in the end they what they concluded is
that course overall was would would be
about five seconds slower than if they'd
been able to come up with a hypothetical
track that was perfectly straight and
perfectly flat and just you know 26.2
miles in a straight line along like the
salt salt flats of in the Utah desert or
whatever yes so five seconds a you know
if he had run two flat zero and three
seconds they would have said but but
they decided that that was pretty close
that it wasn't it wasn't a big deal if
it had been 20 seconds on the curves
thirty seconds on the curves they would
have been more concerned and the other
thing they could have done is if it had
been significant they would have altered
the pacer
around the curve so that he wasn't
working too hard around the curves there
what is it let's slow down a bit on the
curves so that you're not pushing into
the red zone got you okay so we've got
the track we've got Kip Cho gay he's
been doing his 140 miles a week which is
I mean that's gotta be pretty extreme
even for like a normal marathon practice
or is that is that in the normal window
for a world class marathoner that's in
the normal window it's on the high end
it's there's certainly people who do
less but yeah if you go to the if you go
to the start line of the Olympic
marathon and do a little survey you'll
find quite a number of people will have
hit 140 miles so anyway we've got him
there and then he's got how many how
many paces seventy paces did you say
he's got a total total group I think it
was 41 Pacers including like Olympic
champions world champion so some of the
best runners in the world and but you
were getting paid reasonably well I
think and they were divided into teams
of I think it was seven runners so I've
been hiding two behind yet exactly the
two behind was it was a was a sort of
surprise that was another difference
from the last time because you'd say
well who cares why is there someone
behind him they'd like to push him
forward if he falls down but they ran
these simulations these Windtunnel tests
and computational fluid dynamics
simulations and determined and cyclists
know this - because cyclists have
thought about drafting before it's
faster to be in the middle of the
peloton than at the back of the peloton
and the reason is you want the air to be
as smooth as possible going past you and
if you're that you're at the back the
air behind you is kind of turbulent very
messy you've got two people behind you
the air just keeps flowing right past
you and then the turbulence is pushed
back behind the last pacemaker yeah if
you've ever been driving on the motorway
behind a big truck and you're closed and
then that truck pulls away a little bit
and you start to then catch where those
those winds start to cross over it's
really ugly it's like a lot of a lot
turbulence that's exactly yeah that's it
that's that's the perfect analogy Kip
Jogi wasn't going as fast as a truck but
I've seen some trucks in the UK that go
about as quick as he did so we've set
them away we've got a guy we've got a
man with a wonderful moustache who's one
of the pacemakers great moustache mate
been a couple of mustaches a lot more
white athletes than I actually thought
at that very very top end of it I would
have thought it would have been I think
breaking two was heavily
a kenyan african-based and it seemed
like any us had really pulled out every
athlete from everywhere that they could
I think they were I you know I'm not I'm
speculating here I suspect they were
consciously trying to make it a globally
appealing event so they had they had
several American athletes they had
Australian athletes I came from forth
and he had British athletes
representative pacemakers oh yeah yes so
they were they brought together all
those guys were amazing they're all you
know near the top and then they had
Norwegian athletes the three Norwegian
brothers the Inga Britain's who were the
first time it three brothers have ever
made the World Championship final this
year so anyway they had they had but I
think they were they were just saying
let's find the cheapest pacemakers we
can they were like let's find people who
are all world-class but let's also give
people around the world a reason to tune
in that's awesome I really like the idea
so we're on to the race they've set away
they actually started off on a section
of the track that the only ever run once
didn't they so this yeah on this like
pink a decline sorry and that's free
time so they so before they start before
they got on to this loop they did a
about a 500 meter down a bridge which I
think it descended 13 14 meters and the
calculation was that that actually saved
about 10 seconds and before you say hey
that's cheating
the the official IWF rules for world
records on in road races you're allowed
to have a little bit of a downhill and
it's you're allowed to have a 1 in 1000
ratio descent so that means for a 42
kilometer
you're allowed to go down for 42 meters
and so and they they only went down and
I think 13 meters so they took advantage
of about a third of the allowable
downhill that they could have put in the
race and you know 10 seconds could have
that's actually you know I don't know if
anything would have been nice if they
could have got a little more downhill
but bridge the bridge a lot of them to
extend the bridge up a bit more you you
want to have 40 1.9 meters like you
maybe ideally you want to have that that
descent and you probably wanted at the
end where they're tired but anyway they
couldn't they couldn't get everything
exactly you'd have to kind of get the
earthmovers out to build the actual
perfect course Joey so moving on to the
race how did you cuz did you watch it
live did you get to watch it live I did
it started at 2:15 in the morning my
time so I have very few memories of the
the first 45 minutes of the race but I
finally was awake by about 3:00 in the
morning I was like I think this is
happening I think this is gonna gonna be
something so what did you yeah you're
watching it you're analyzing him you
know this is what you do how did you did
you feel did he look worried at any
point did you assess his running form
yeah you know so I did I was worried
about just before halfway he started to
drift back a little bit he there a gap
opened up between him and the pacemaker
in front of him and he didn't look too
happy and I thought man if he's
struggling now I think this is gonna be
trouble now after the race he reportedly
said people ask him about that because
that wasn't the only person who noticed
that and he was like no I don't know
what you're talking about I felt great
the whole way so I don't know if that's
just a little bit of revisionist history
you know you don't always remember what
you're thinking in the middle of the
race or it was just he he was not you
know not paying attention or something
but so I was I was I was watching for
little signs like that I was it was
interesting because I so I was in for
the Nike race a couple years ago I was
there in Italy and at that point I X for
that race I expected to feel kind of
cynical because it was you know it was a
sort of big Nike marketing stunt as well
as an athletic event and I ended up
feeling totally blown away by the sort
of magical feeling of that breaking - so
this time I think my expectations were a
little higher I was like could take me
to that special place L yet I want to
you know exactly and you know it was it
was special but it was it was less
surprising because he'd already been
within 25 seconds so instead of feeling
like I can't believe he's doing this I
was more feeling like I hope he doesn't
screw up because there's no second place
in this race like he doesn't do it
that's 15 million pounds down the drain
and if that's everyone just you know
that's a night of sleep like I'll tell
you I was I was wiped out for the whole
weekend so there was a little bit more
of just kind of like just do it already
I lied and I hate to say that it was
still magical but it was just
the second time is never the same as the
first I agree I think to give any us who
are in it there is an engineering
company right there a petrochemical
company and obviously that I mean the
tie-ins with running a make perfect
sense yeah of course yeah yeah cuz if
you want to fuel up I guess on the way
home from the race no I think I think
they just wanted their their name out
there yeah okay well if you got the
money but yeah there was something
you're right I'll be interested to see
there'll be a after movie documentary
thing coming up eventually I'm gonna I'm
gonna guess but yeah the the night break
into it really did feel very special
like I loved I loved how that you know
they got Kevin obviously it's night like
they've you know when you think about
the people that they can call in like
who the [ __ ] in EOS like you ain't
call in like a like a petrol pump
attendant or somebody who's like really
wants to do marathon but yeah like the
Nike one really did feel magical and
you're right maybe the magic wasn't as
optimal starting in this misty morning
in Monza where they've got no crowd and
it's just deathly silent and you've got
this Tesla that just just pulls away and
that's it and like there was but it was
it was special no I wouldn't I wouldn't
do what would have happened how do
you've done it on that first time I
wonder how how people might have changed
and so so getting on to one of the more
major controversies that's going on at
the moment before we talk about some
other records have been broken recently
the shooter Elliott had on for the first
one was was a again a new a new
iteration of a line of shoes and then
they've then taken it up a notch for
this can you can you talk us through how
they relate yeah and this is really
important because I don't I don't think
we could talk about this race without
talking about the shoes
because I don't think we would be having
this discussion or be here if it wasn't
for a major change in shoe technology
that took place in 2016 and Nike
introduced a new line of shoes which has
to two distinct features one is a stiff
carbon fiber plate that goes through the
the midsole and the other is that the
midsole was made of this new ultra light
ultra resilient foam and by resilient I
mean you squeeze it down and it springs
back really quickly and so marathon
flats used to be as thin as possible you
want it to be racing in a shoe that
weighed nothing and so they're basically
just a piece of rubber wrapped around
your feet now they're these big thick
hey you know I more than an inch thick
is the sole of this foam this
lightweight foam and then it's got a
carbon fiber plate through the middle of
it and comical if you look at the the
shoes that they're wearing now at the
start of the race it looks funny shoes
it's sort of taking us back to the 70s
it's a they look like sort of running
pimps or something like that and it's
you know initially when Nike introduced
new shoes no one believed they worked so
they're like it's all a big stunt you
know all the magic is in the drafting or
the the course and they they're just
trying to sell us these shoes but it's
become clear that no the the data was
true these shoes really are several
percent better than any previous shoe
and the sort of all time lists and
records have been rewritten over the
last two years and it's not just that
one pair of shoes so so Kip shogi was
two years ago was wearing the initial
line of the shoe since then they've had
a second iteration it was the vapor fly
four percent then the vapor flying next
percent and now cap Choji was wearing
yet another shoe that is even which
looks even wackier than the previous
ones because it's got these two pods
under the forefoot in addition to the
thick sole and it's thicker even thicker
than the initial like the initial ones
were something like 31 millimeters thick
and apparently the prototype although no
one has been allowed to touch it yet is
pushing 40 millimeters which is I don't
know if you know a lot of people have
heard about
Hoka shoes which are these big super
cushy maximalist shoes that that with
thick soles the nike shoes are even
thicker than these sort of clown shoes
that everyone used to make fun of so it
sparked a big controversy because when
you have a shoe that's that much better
and it's made by one company insect and
not everyone has access to the newest
prototypes then you start to ask hang on
it
it is it is the shoe determining who's
winning the race of we moved to a
Formula one model where it's an
engineering competition rather than a
stock car model where everyone's driving
the same car yeah it's strange I think
you know for me as someone who if you
tried to put 26 and a bit miles in front
of me like you could put me in a pair of
rollerblades and I'm not making it but I
wonder just how much of a difference the
shoes might are I would be skeptical
until reading and hearing more about it
I think how it's just a pair of shoes I
can't make that much of a difference so
it you know if the goal is you know mean
my mates are gonna run a marathon in a
year just as a big challenge and then we
want to make it to the finish yeah you
know doesn't really matter about the
shoes if you're if you're racing
yourself and if you're trying to set a
best time or if you're trying to hit an
external time like the Boston Marathon
qualifying standard or something like
that then all of a sudden you start
really paying attention to two minutes
here three minutes there and there was a
big so for the elites is one thing there
was a big the New York Times did a big
crowdsourced analysis a year or two ago
where they they used data from Strava
which is this online platform that you
know where people upload their their
runs from GPS including their races and
they sometimes record which shoes
they're wearing so they said let's look
at the same runners who have switched
from one shoe to another either from
another shoe to the to the vapor fly or
the vapor fly to another shoe and what
they found was more or less exactly what
mike leake Nike was claiming the runners
were a couple of minutes a couple of
percent faster in the vapor fly than
they were in other shoes that's so crazy
so what's the what does that pod do if
you got any idea what the the pod is
that similar to there is it the joyride
or the float ride that they've just
brought out that Nike brought out I
might yeah I'm not sure I'm not sure
that's got that's a pod that's got
little beads inside of the pod like a
bean bag okay so that's that they
recently brought that out but the thing
that Elliot's got looks a lot more like
hardcore than that yeah so the only the
only information we have is that there
is a patent filing that someone
unearthed that looks like capture gaez
prototype and so people are speculating
that this is what's an issue it's not
clear that
but the pod itself had these sort of
fibers within it that get tensed and
stretched like it
this is serious space-age [ __ ] isn't it
yeah and here's that here's the thing
it's like shoe companies have been
making these crazy claims for technology
for as long as I've been alive every
every year there's a new it's like we're
introducing the Nike shocks we're
introducing you know the the gel this or
the torsion that or whatever and it's
and there's always this complicated
plausible sounding explanation of why
this is gonna be the best thing since
sliced bread and the the sort of the
heuristic that I learned over the years
is just ignore all that because it's
never true it never makes a difference
all this stuff is just noise and so
that's why the Nike shoe caught everyone
by surprise so it was like whoa this
really works so now they're good they're
still doing the same thing they're still
so here's these paw pods and the pods
have torsion or beads or whatever the
heck you want my default is still to say
probably doesn't do anything like let's
just ignore what that is we've been
wrong once the carbon fiber plates in
the foam really did do something and
we'll see whether the pods do something
more but if that may the pods may just
be sort of a you know pay no attention
to the to the you know the man in the
big hat or whatever like a distraction
to the fact that they actually the other
thing in this prototype or in this
patent application is they suggested
they could have up to three carbon fiber
plates in the shoe so maybe it's all
still all about the carbon fiber plates
in the foam or maybe the pods do
something but that claim hasn't been
tested by scientists
unlike the carbon fiber plate got you so
what have been some of the criticisms
then of this particular run from the
running purists and the people that
you'll you'll have to see having their
bickerings online what what have people
been saying yeah well that you know how
long do you have because there's you
know there's there's a there's a cup
there's two basically two basic things
one is the sort of general criticism of
exhibition races like this that they
should have been done you know like my
grandfather used to run a marathon you
know this is how we run races and this
is how it always should be I hate all
this publicity and this
advertising and I think that's that's
basically grumpiness and I you know I
understand whatever but yeah I'm not to
me that doesn't carry a lot of water if
they know if they're not interested they
don't have to pay attention to it but
the other criticism is more based on the
shoes and you know to understand that
you have to go back to 2016 so no one
knew these shoes existed they weren't
publicly announced until mid 2017 but a
select few Nike runners were given
prototypes of the shoes which were
specially fabricated to disguise what
they were they were disguised as zoom
streak sixes so they looked like old
shoes but they actually had these carbon
fiber blades in the foam in them they
took these shoes they went to the
Olympics they swept the top three spots
in the men's marathon and they also won
the women's marathon no way so now
you've got a situation where you've got
a shoe that helps and only a few people
have it and their takes weeping the
medals and so people are like that's not
fair that's not fair that a race should
be among the runner is not among who
happens to be favored by Nike and given
the best shoes and I have I have a lot
of sympathy for that argument in fact I
agree with it I think that was not that
was not kosher and that that should not
be done now the IWF the governing body
of track changed the rules the next year
to say okay any shoe that we're not
gonna ban carbon-fiber plates but any
shoe used must be widely available to
all yeah in the spirit of the university
universality of athletics now that rule
is now on the books but it hasn't
changed anything people are using
prototypes elite athletes are still
using unreleased prototypes so I don't
know why they put the rule in if they're
not actually gonna be enforcing it but
that's where so that's where I think the
real meat of the controversy is first of
all is it is it fair to have these shoes
and that's a I think banning the shoes
you know I can see arguments on both
sides but there should definitely be
regulations or rules to make sure that
there aren't that only a few people you
don't have this situation where only a
few people have a shoe and nobody else
doesn't and it's making an appreciable
difference that's just not how I feel
Olympics what about if
about if the shoes available to all but
your you as an athlete you were with a
different sponsor yeah so that gets a
little that gets tricky and there have
been some amazing amazing instances of
runners at like the World Championships
running in the Nike shoes but having
painted them to look like they're their
assets so painting the end for New
Balance onto the Vapor flies and they
get busted people people are there with
with cameras and like look at this dude
and I personally know a couple of people
who've lost their sponsorships because
they raced in Nike shoes and I and I you
know there's there's a guy I know a
number of you know elite marathons with
sponsorships and one of them was saying
recently it's like I have to decide is
it worth it to me the relatively small
amount of money that I get from shoe
company X to race in a slower shoe or
should I just give up my sponsorship so
that I can because maybe I'll make so
much more prize money if I'm a minute or
two faster so this is this is a real
challenge I think the best-case scenario
there's a few different paths we could
go but probably the best case scenario
is that other shoe companies come out
with comparable shoes and then everyone
we can be back to where we were five
years ago where it's like yeah there are
differences between shoes but it's not
determining races and there are at least
three and probably more companies that
have their elite runners racing in
prototypes that have carbon-fiber plates
in them so I think that's and in fact we
were talking about this before we
started recording last weekend the
Ironman World Championships the
resilient fur Dino from Germany set a
new course record at the Ironman World
Championships he was wearing a sixth use
but they had a carbon-fiber plate in
them so that's maybe one way that the
playing field is going to be real Evald
is that and everyone else is gonna catch
up and everything so these shoes are
gonna be widely available the only
difference is now that ten years on ten
years all the numbers are going to be
maybe 2% to 4% quicker across the board
so before we started there was a
screenshot that I saw it's quite cool
for anyone who wants to keep up to date
with the new shoes and what's going on
protoss of the Grampy ro tos of the gram
on Instagram is quite a cool
account and they Reshard a post from a
guy called Reinhold now I'll read this
out and then I'll let you I let you take
us through what's actually happening
here Alex but so a train hall three with
all due respect to a lead capture gay as
he is quite clearly the greatest
marathoner of all time irregardless of
the shoes he is in when a shoe company
puts multiple carbon fiber plates an
issue with cushion between the plates it
is no longer a shoe it's a spring and a
clear mechanical advantage to anyone not
in those shoes I'm just hoping that IAF
athletics make sure that the upcoming
Olympics and WM majors are fair playing
fields for athletes of all brands and
then this protis of the grammars Reshard
that photo and said can someone please
tell Ryan hall three that the new asacs
prototype his wife ran a marathon PB and
has as we quote John for a Danis
interview think of it as a rocking chair
it has a carbon-fiber plate in and is
the answer to the four percent of the
competition as we also quote Sarah's
answer in the let's run comm interview
run in a prototype of the new Essex
marathon shoe it does not have a
carbon-fiber plate so I do not attribute
my PR to the shoe why are you lying
Sarah other brands need to up their game
to catch up to night running what are
you barging going on here yeah so Ryan
Hall is one of the greatest American
marathoners in history he retired a few
years ago he's he he plays pretty highly
at the London Marathon and one of his
first marathons he ran like 206 over a
very very well-known athlete here in
North America his wife Sarah Hall is
still competing and recently in in
Berlin ran at 222 marathon making her
the I think it's the fourth fastest
American in history so these are two a
couple which are who are both among the
fastest marathons in history both
sponsored by Asics so Ryan is is getting
a little preachy here about Nike and
this is one of the sort of dynamics that
makes this shoe in debate so interesting
is that everyone's got a vested interest
the people you know everyone who's
defending it everyone who's
criticizing it if you're an elite runner
or involved in elite running almost
everyone in that world has an
affiliation to a shoe company so it's
hard to tease out what's a sort of
principled stand against you know the
technology and running shoes and what is
it like hey that's no fair I wish I had
those shoes and so so anyway in the
comments yes so you know Ryan Hall is
criticizing these spring shoes and I
think that's I think that reflects on
him maybe an imperfect understanding of
what's going on with the shoes cuz
they're not they're not Springs any more
than any other pair of shoes is spring
every every shoe has squishy mid soles
and they act as a spring the
carbon-fiber plate isn't a spring it's a
stiffening a stiffening element but
anyway that's kind of beside the point
Ryan's calling out these shoes someone
else pointing out actually your wife ran
an unreleased prototype in Berlin yeah
just a few weeks ago and they were
speculating that it was the same
carbon-fiber plate prototype that Yan
frodeno ran at the at the Ironman World
Championships last week
however Sarah Hall has gone on record as
saying that actually her prototypes
don't have a carbon-fiber plate now she
still did say that they're unreleased
prototypes and the iwf rule is crystal
clear now that you can't run in shoes
that aren't generally available to all
so I'm a little mystified by whether
this rule is just there for decoration
or whether you know it enforced at some
point yeah I mean I guess they need to
give a warning because it's happening so
commonly but it's it's pretty clear to
me that that she's she's publicly saying
yes I did this thing that is against the
rule so I would be a little cautious if
I were Ryan and Sarah about chucking
chucking stones through windows because
they are as far as I can tell in in
violation of the rules but the point the
point is Ryan's argument appears to be
predicated on the fact that this
carbon-fiber plate shoe technology is
advanced any other technology advances
as you've said before they're just kind
of nondescript and they don't really
matter but obviously that shoe let's say
the asacs have come up with something
they probably haven't but let's say that
they've come up with something which is
even better than a carbon-fiber plate
you still contravene the rules you'd
still use something which is a none
really
prototype all that you're just it's
apples and oranges here right like it's
you
criticizing one thing because of its
type not because of the the principle
that's exactly it and the history of the
carbon fiber plate is actually very very
very interesting because it Nike didn't
invent this carbon fiber plate in fact
adidas is the company that sponsored the
development of the carbon fiber plate
that may had in fact Halley Gabrus
Selassie said a marathon world record in
Adidas shoes in 2007 that had a carbon
fiber plate the guy who developed that
carbon fiber plate not to get into the
Nitty Gritty here but he's an academic
at the University of Calgary here in
Canada one of his PhD students then went
to Nike plate that is in the Nike shoe
is a direct lineal descendant of the one
in the adidas shoe and same with the
foam that Nikes foam does exactly what
adidas is foam which was called the
boost did and they had five consecutive
world record marathon records in the
boost foam which was Brazilian so all
the ingredients of the Nike shoe are
things that other shoe companies and
adidas wasn't the only one Fela and
Asics and I think Hoka all had carbon
fiber yeah there was a little list at
the bottom of that thing Hoka has a play
asacs Brooks running has a play saucony
New Balance have plates yeah and some of
those have been since the the vapor fly
but some of them were long before the
vapor fly so people are all of a sudden
saying oh my god carbon fiber plates are
cheating it's like nobody cared about
carbon fiber plates when they weren't
beating you so there's I think there's a
lot of self-interest and in the
criticism and that's why I I'm sort of
skeptical of that we should ban carbon
fiber plates because people are getting
were self-righteous about the plate
itself and it's like it's not the plate
it's the fact that it works mmm that's
the problem
and so the Roza proposal published
yesterday or the day before in the
British Journal of Sports Medicine on
how to regulate shoes how to stop it
from getting out of hand so that people
don't end up wearing what look like ski
boots or something like that
disconnected from what we think of as
running boots and they said look let's
not get bogged down with like can you
have a carbon fiber plate no well what
about
fiberglass plate can you have a plastic
plate well how long can the plate be
let's get every before every race you
have to go through the MRI and test your
shoes that's that's a that's a pain in
the neck let's just put a limit on the
thickness of shoe soles that already
exists for high jump shoes because I
can't remember 4-year fifty years ago so
someone started being like hey if I'm
trying to jump high why don't I just
wear platform shoes and so they started
wearing thicker and thicker shoes so the
idea Blatt said okay you can only have
shoes this thick like I don't know the
exact number to do high jump which made
sense so they should do the same for
running shoes you can and this is what
the proposal is from in the British
Journal of Sports Medicine with the same
mentions you can fit whatever technology
you want you just got this much room
that you can put it in yeah let's say
you have 31 millimeters you can stick a
carbon fiber plate you can stick to you
can stick your fancy pods or whatever
you want but you're not gonna have
unlimited real estate because what's
happened with the with the the three
successive versions of the vapor fly is
they've gotten thicker and thicker
they've gotten about 25 percent thicker
to the point where it really they really
do look funny yeah it's not all about
aesthetics but it's a point where it's
like running supposed to be a simple
sport let's make sure it doesn't look
like you're like it's a tech an
equipment dominated sport so let's just
put take the simplest rule possible at
least say you cannot wear a platform
shoes mmm yeah totally right I guess
it's well the thing is there would come
a time where you would add so much
thickness onto the bottom of the shoe it
would become heavy so heavy that you
would then begin to lose marginal gains
if there was a like if you got rid of
this particular ruling and well that
right people have started wearing
seven-inch thick soles but how does that
change your running mechanics and your
running gait how does that then add
weight onto the bottom of the leg and
stuff like that so yeah I think
whoever's come up with that British
Journal of Medicine or whatever it was a
sort of sports science I think that's a
fairly good approach so there was there
was something else that you'd mentioned
before if there been some other records
have been broken recently there was the
Iron Man there was there was Eliot and
then what else yeah so the the women's
record women's world record for the
marathon went down the day after Elliot
kept choji's sub-2 and this was to me it
was actually more surprising than
because Elliot was already 25 seconds
from the barrier we kind of knew that it
could happen even though it was gonna be
easy but then the next day in Chicago
Bridget Koz gay broke Paula Radcliffe's
marathon world record Paula Paula's
record had was to 1525 and it had stood
since 2003 and basically no one had come
within him while not a mile but no one
had come within shouting distance of
that record meri Cattani I think was the
second fastest and she was like 217
something yeah yeah like ages ages off
and then out of nowhere absolutely
nowhere or you know not quickly nowhere
but very surprisingly all of a sudden
Bridgette cascade this Canyon runner ran
to 1404 so smashed Paula's record by
over a minute in Chicago off a very fast
pace it wasn't even optimally paced and
after the race she said yeah I think a
lady can run 210 I'm gonna keep trying
it so it's like what you know and and
and needless to say the important you
know maybe the first thing I should say
is she was wearing Nikes paper flies
this is the discussion that we're having
now that every performance that's good
got to be caveated with an asterisk
that's talking about it was in this pair
of shoes i reaiiy hope i really do hope
for the sport that they just work out
what the rule is implemented hard lines
and and everyone can get back to talking
about running I had percent agree it's
it's it's it's unfortunate that that's
the discussion and so it's
understandable that some people would
say therefore we wish the shoe had been
banned
you know strangled at birth and just
gotten rid of and and maybe that would
have been the best situation but it's
not it's not what's happened and at this
point I think they're beep it would be
more trouble or more disruptive than
it's worth to try and like erase all the
records that have been set in these
shoes so I think we have to say ok this
is where we're at but let's put and this
is what the British Journal of Sports
Medicine paper says let's let's put a
limit on where we're at now and not let
it go any farther let's and then the
because the most disorienting thing is
when the standards are changing every
six months and and faster once once they
settle into a new stasis even if it's
than it was five years ago what we'll
get used to that yeah cuz we've gotten
used to it in many other sports before
it's like okay now speed skaters have
clap skates on everyone's faster than
they were in the 90s but we're not
arguing about it every six months it was
there was a brief period of disruption
in the late 90s and then it was done and
even with the swimsuits in 2010 I guess
it was you know records were just
falling falling falling they said okay
here's where we're gonna set the line of
what swimsuits are allowed and then
since then it's it's kind of a non-issue
now so I think running can do that but
they need to they need to set a you know
set some rules now so that people
understand what the parameters are and
what's allowed and what's not it's
interesting it's quite a philosophical
debate or quite a philosophical thought
about what are you allowing to be
enhanced with regards to an athlete for
instance if you were if someone had come
up with some unbelievable new intra
workout nutrition drink which was able
to fuel muscles at ten times the pace or
what did you know I mean like if it was
where are we allowing this to happen and
where are we not I think it's because it
feels somehow because the shoe is not a
part of the athlete is not literally
integral to the athlete is just perhaps
why people feel a bit sort of icky about
it yeah and it's funny you should say
that because they're the other
innovation in the last two years has
been a new sports drink we called Morton
made by a small Swedish company where it
has Morton ma you are te n okay cool and
the the claim is that it has these two
ingredients pectin and alginate I think
that made from like seaweed or something
like that
yeah and it's other than that it's a
standard sports drink it's got a bunch
of carbohydrates in it you swallow it
and when the when those ingredients get
in your stomach they react with the
stomach acid to create a hydrogel which
kind of encapsulate the carbohydrates
effectively sort of hiding them from
your stomach normally if you try and
take in a bunch of carbohydrate when
you're exercising you reach a point
where it you can't handle anymore your
stomach rebels and you either get
diarrhea or you vomit or you just you
just feel like crap the hydrogel hides
this carbohydrate it's in your stomach
but you don't eat you're not even you're
not detecting it then it goes into your
intestines and is absorbed into your
bloodstream so
the claim is that you can drink much
higher concentrations of carbohydrate
and to get more fuel in during a
marathon or other endurance activity
without messing up here in the
gastrointestinal system and this is
swept the endurance world in the last
couple of years it's people everyone
loves it
there's been no data showing that it
actually works the way it claims you
know but my question is always how do we
know you're not just pooping out a bunch
of hydrogel you know six hours later or
twelve hours or whatever the deal is but
Kip Jogi for example is swears by Morton
heli coupe shogi does lots of the top
endurance athletes in the world so their
hat and no one is saying man hydrogels
this is unacceptable on now partly
that's cuz no one knows whether it
really for sure makes such a big
difference it's much easier to finger
but I think what you say is also true
that it really it's a it's a sort of
what does it feel like test and and you
know the role of sports technology or
the role of aids and technologies is a
tricky issue you know I've been writing
recently about electric brain
stimulation with the idea that you hook
up electrodes to your brain run some
current through your and and it makes
you able to push a little harder for
about an hour or two and I've been
really wrestling with that so it feet
that also feels icky to me why should it
be banned why would I say that should be
banned whereas you know all these other
things like sports drinks should be
banned yeah caffeine you just taking a
pill and it makes you faster or taking
us a coffee or whatever so I don't think
there's a I don't people the people who
say it's a hundred percent obvious that
X should be banned and why shouldn't be
banned i I don't agree with them I I
think it's it's always going to be a
subjective line and what we need to do
what sports governing bodies need to do
and fans like us need to do is think
about what what what makes us feel
comfortable or uncomfortable what is it
about so running for example is a very
simple sport right like we were talking
about earlier so the the to have a big
effect of an external technology like
shoe feels different than it would in a
sport that's much more gear dependent
like cycling cycling of course your gear
matters it's not you know you're never
gonna
that the bike is irrelevant but in
running we at least have the illusion
that it's you know mano-a-mano and so I
think we have less tolerance for
technology like that and I think that's
okay I think we have to respect the
cultures of different sports totally
right so what I want to finish on was an
article which had seen you sharing
recently to do with the is it the
suicide pace that people go out at yeah
I know I found that I found that really
just fascinating give me can you take us
through that yeah sure so the World
Athletics Championships just wrapped up
last month in or a few weeks ago in
Qatar and you know I spent a week or
whatever watching all these races
streaming them online and there was
something really unique about this year
which was that the the dist middle
distance in long distance races almost
universally went out really really fast
not like let's just judge our pace
carefully and go fast but like I'm gonna
go out and I might die that anyone who's
gonna come with me is gonna die too and
that's really unusual because the the
for the last 15 or 20 years the standard
thing in endurance in championship
racing not not time trial racing but in
trying to win a goal as I say the
Olympics is everyone goes out really
slowly and watches their competitors
because there's a real sense that if
you're out in front you're the hunted
and if you're lurking behind someone
you're the hunter I'm if there's some
aerodynamic stuff to do that if you're
leading your year sort of breaking win
for everyone else but it's I think it's
more than that it's psychological this
feeling of if you're the one who's
stalking your prey you can choose one to
pounce and then when you see the finish
line you pounce you go by them they'll
have a chance to react em it's over so
it's sort of like these cycling pursuit
races where they could almost go as slow
as possible yeah and those races can be
fun to watch but it's interesting
because then you end up with really slow
times and and and and then this year was
totally different there were none of
those sort of cat-and-mouse chess match
games it was like gun goes I'm throwing
down the gloves and I am going balls to
the wall to see and and see who could
last and so the times were
extraordinarily fast
just the way they were run so I ran some
analyses I calculated what I called the
camicazi index how fast did the races
start compared to their average pace and
it's and it turned out that this year
was anomalous compared to the last 20
years it was the there's there's this
cultural shift for some reason and it's
hard to know like did all the runners
run did one run or do it and then
everyone else was like well it worked
for that guy I'm gonna try that and some
of them while I'm gonna try that and
everyone try it so is is interesting to
watch it's not that one caper race is
better than others but it was
fascinating to see people letting it all
hang out and it may you know just from a
personal perspective and a sort of
applying this to general life until the
rest of us it made me look back at the
way I often run races which is very
cautiously I don't want to blow up and
I've thought a lot about this in you
know in recent years just in the context
of endurance that I think if you really
want to find your limits sometimes you
have to blow up sometimes you have to go
out too fast yeah um and you know
hopefully you go out faster than you
usually do and you discover oh wait I
can maintain hold on yeah yeah and
that's great then you set a new best
time sometimes you discover ah no no it
turns out I can't reverse that's fine so
you gotta you gotta chalk that up as a
valuable learning experience and say if
you really want to find out what your
limits are sometimes you've got to
exceed them and crash and burn yeah I
love that and you write as well there's
part of me that just loves the idea of
of someone going out beyond what they
usually would and then watching them
hold on it's the same way so the
CrossFit opens out at the moment and
right now workout 20.2 just got released
which is just a grinder 20 minutes amrap
of dumbbell thrusters toaster bar and
double unders and it's just the
grittiest longest most painful thing
that Dave Castro has ever programmed
it's savage and I'm watching the guys in
the gym do this morning and Jordan who
has got the same score as Khan Porter
the guy that did the announcement Jordan
who's ex regionals athlete in Newcastle
absolute freak and I'm watching him go
out and it's a 20-minute workout and
he's going sub one minute from the
get-go so he's doing rounds in 45 to 50
seconds his transitions are rapid and
I'm like oh he's
hard because once you've set yourself on
that it's the same with running right to
your splits it's like okay I'm on this
particular split whatever it might be
you want to try and run negative split
you want to try and run quicker if you
can and I'm watching I'm thinking he's
gonna have to hold on sure enough three
two one and time clock goes Jordan stray
outside because he needs to make sure
that if he throws up he throws up in a
drain and he's just like I want to watch
that I wanna and I wanna watch that on
the world stage as well I want to know
that professionals can be as giddy and
as a caught in the moment as we can and
you want to see them stretch their
limits not just totally under control
the whole way you want to see the fear
in their eyes two-thirds of the way oh
yeah oh yeah you could and you can see
and some of them did blow up some of
some of the people who tried to stay
with him like when you when we're races
go like that you see carnage you see
what happens when a world-class athlete
hits the wall and yeah it's it's I mean
I'm not saying I I'm sure they didn't
enjoy it but it's it's fun to see cuz
then you know yeah this is this is legit
this is that they're stretched to their
limits - there's no yes yeah I love it
a final thing just as a parting point
the one thing that we haven't actually
said how fast was Elliot Kipchoge a
running during his marathon attempt in
brief I would say faster than most
people could like I've chatted a lot of
people at this there's a lot of people
in the world most people in the world
just wouldn't be able to like sprint
that fast for ten seconds like he was
doing 434 per mile maybe 433 and that's
like to 249 per kilometer so that's it's
for a 200 meters that's something like
33 34 so 16 to 17 seconds per 100 meters
so is it about 12 miles an hour
is that it what is it not so so it's 13
in a bit miles an hour and then the
difference between 12 and 13 is enormous
when you're at that speed 13 and a bit
miles an hour in a car is a moderately
heavy accident I mean like if you fall
over at that pace you're gonna skid for
a while
yeah I mean I think a lot of people
would have would be challenged to keep
up with him on a bike it was certainly
for longer than you know a brief sprint
like it it's it's almost unfortunate
that he's such a smooth looking runner
and that he was surrounded by pacemakers
who are among the best in the world
because you don't realize how fast he
was going except sometimes during the
broadcast you see off to the side
someone has decided outside the
barricades to run along beside him and
what you see is someone who looks quite
fit who's probably like a very serious
recreational runner and they are just
absolute pegging it absolutely good you
know just giving it with their whole
being and they last you know 15 seconds
tops
then you're like oh okay just because
this is quick looks relaxed just because
he's gliding along as if he's you know
floating on air doesn't mean he's not
really booking it how fascinating Alex
today has been absolutely awesome to the
listeners who didn't catch our first
episode number 49 I want to say 48 or 49
it was the first episode of this year
still in the top 10 of all time plays on
modern wisdom it will be linked in the
show notes below I implore you to go and
check that out also enjoy Alex's book
absolutely fantastic great analysis if
you're into this and like I said at
sweat science on Twitter everything will
be linked in the show notes below any
questions that you've got go Hassell
Alex who's on Twitter all the time or
leave them in the youtube comments below
okay I want I want there to be some more
athletic stuff coming up so that I can I
can hassle you again I can get you back
on man it's the great thing every year
there's some new awesome
I like so thanks so much for your time
it's been great thanks miss this was
really fun to go into the nitty-gritty
[Music]